good morning believe nation today's
message is start mentoring over to you
now Rihanna Murphy the primary objective
of every leader is to ensure that there
is successive generation of leaders and
one of the instruments for doing that is
mentoring mentoring is a private
relationship it's a voluntary
relationship the mentee chooses the
mentor at mphasis so it's an honest one
it's one where the the amount the moral
dilemma the value system etc etcetera
can be discussed openly and honestly and
hopefully the mentor will use his or her
experiential base to give some solutions
so mentorship is a super important topic
and in this clip he's talking about how
you need to mentor and give back and I
think that that's a really important
message whether you are bringing
somebody new one to your team and trying
to mentor and you may not be thinking
kind of multi-generational yet right you
may not be thinking how do I sell my
business or how do I make sure it
continues beyond my existence right now
a lot of you're probably thinking how do
I just get my business up and running
how do I make it sustainable how do I
provide an income for myself and so I
think magic can play two important roles
one I think yes you should be a mentor
you should be a mentor to people who you
bringing up in your organization to new
hires that you're bringing on board you
should dedicate time to making them
better understanding what their
interests are and having having them
feel like they're learning because if
they are not learning they're going to
leave and go do something else I think
as well entrepreneurs have
responsibility to mint with the people
around them right to build up and lift
your community to make your community
rise up right I want Toronto
entrepreneurs to be better i want global
entrepreneurs we better but i do a lot
of work in my local community because i
believe it's a responsibility that you
have as an entrepreneur to give back and
help others now let's flip the other
side around is not talked about in the
clip but i think is really important
and that you need to find mentors
yourself right you need to find people
who you can talk to one on one who are
in your local community you need to find
people who are online you may not have
met before watching these videos as an
example and what I call aspirational
mentors these people who look up to who
you want to be like who you can learn
something from even though you may never
meet them they may be dead right my
first real mentor was Bill Gates my
family with great mentors my parents
were mentors and that they taught me my
belief system my bio system but they're
not entrepreneurs my first
entrepreneurial mentor goes bill gates
and looked at how did he get started how
did he build his business and I've never
met Bill Gates I may one day but other
mentors of mind have been AP Giannini
who started bank of america and Steve
Jobs and these guys have passed away and
I'll never get the chance to meet them
but I can learn a lot from them and so I
would start looking at you know whatever
problem you have right now it has
already been solved people has already
solved the problem that you are
currently facing over and over and over
and over and over again and instead of
you trying to come up with genius ideas
every time you can look to who has
already solved this and how can I model
their success and so if you can connect
with aspirational mentors right find
people who look up to inside your
industry and outside your industry look
at how they got started I guarantee you
you'll find ideas and how you can apply
that to your business second I look at
people online YouTube channels bloggers
that you follow reporters that you like
entrepreneurs on Twitter or social media
that you look up to that you respect if
you're watching shark tank or you're
watching the profit or you're watching
these YouTube channels make that a habit
make that consistent so you can start to
to expand your awareness and not just be
locked into your day to day life and the
people who are around you and then three
look at people who might be in your
local community who have had success if
you see somebody speaking at an event
that's close to you you want to learn
from them go reach out try to connect
with them you don't go up and ask them
but hey will you be my mentor cuz that
is a little creepy and it involves a
long term relationship but just asking
somebody out for coffee just asking to
pick their brain with a ten minute phone
call is a lot easier to get a yes and
that can build an ongoing relay
so two sides of it one be a mentor help
others help people in your organization
help people in your community and then
to be MNT I always be learning and try
to reach out and sponge off of other
people because whatever problem that
your face right now has already been
solved many many many times so the
question today today is I'm curious who
some of your biggest mentors have been
who's some of the biggest mentor Z maybe
you've met maybe you haven't met but who
are the people right now who you look up
to and why and leave that in the
comments below I'm really genuinely
curious to find out who your mentors are
so leave it below I will join the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and we'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events presser
ok